[Music]  [Music]  tell me Jacob it isn't me  well looks like we found something  what's that  concealed weapon we're here now the only  question is really actually use it  [Applause]  [Music]  hungry  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  get out friend I know you're faking get  up everyday I was faking I use ninja  focus to slow my heart rate down barring  you  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  kill me  what nobody knows we know each other  you're a stranger you can get away with  this I got a gun in the other room  it's untraceable I'll give you $50,000  don't make me suffer please kill me  begging you please give me like a night  to think about it ha  think about it you would do it oh I hate  you man oh no IRA I misread you  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  ear patch so weird don't decide has the  upper hand on the airbags there's three  left  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]